we're going to go over how to transpose
a matrix
say we have matrix a
and it equals i don't know let's let's
give it a thing
give it some values 2 four nine
six four three
two
uh eight what number haven't we used in
a one
now we wanna transpose this basically
what you do is you turn
the columns into rows
and the rows into columns
and it basically flips so
if this were a matrix you would say
that this
with a t which this means transpose
would equal
well the first row would be the first
column so the first row is going to be
two four nine
and the next one is going to be six four
three
the next one's going to be two four or
two eight one
so there it is transposed
now it's note it's notable that if you
transpose it yet again it goes back to
what it was before
so
you would say that this also equals a
transposed
but that parenthesis there transposed
again
so it just transposes right back now
this is a case with
all
an even size matrix with the matrix is
not even sized
or uh square rather because that was a
three by three we looked at so what if
it's
if it's not what if it's
i don't know let's 2 7 9
6
8
0 for example
so that one there being a three by two
then something a little different
happens
because when you transpose it it then
becomes
a two by three as you might imagine
two seven nine
six eight zero
you'll see how that happens
so now it's a two by three so it does
have that property of
flipping these
which you just don't notice in a square
matrix
let me see is there anything else about
transposing i think that's pretty much
it
there are some properties which i will
go over quickly here
and i'm just going to type them out
because that makes it a little easier
well let's see here i already showed you
one of them if you transpose it back you
get the same thing
so
i'll just go over these real quick so
the first property
which we already sort of touched on is a
transposed transposed again a being a
matrix
equals the same thing
another property is if you scale a
matrix
um let's say this little lambda symbol
here is some scalar number it could be a
5 a 10 or whatever whatever we want to
scale by an a's matrix so we're scaling
it and then we transpose
that
is the same as
scaling it after a transpose two so it
doesn't matter what order you do the
scalar in and where the transpose in it
equals the same thing
and
there's also this property where if you
have two matrices
plus each other and then you transpose
the result
you could also
transpose each of them first
and you get the same thing
and a few more here
well this this scales out as far as you
want you could add in a c here
and
like if you put a plus c here
this would
also you know be there too so that goes
as far as you want
and multiplication is sort of the same
with that rule so if you have
a times b matrix matrices transpose it
is the same as
a transposed times b
transposed
and
yeah this one scales out further as well
like if you have a c in here you would
also have a c here
and that pretty much covers transposing
just remember to flip those columns into
rows
and that's pretty much it
thanks for watching hope this helps with
your matrix math and your transposing
and i'll see you in the next episode
have a good day